[Music]
foreign
first look at what is on the front pages
as they arrive and it's time to see what
is making the headlines with the daily
mails consultant editor Andrew Pierce
and the daily mirrors associate editor
Kevin McGuire lovely to see you guys
they will be with us from now until just
before midnight so let's see what's on
the front of some of those front pages
the financial times has word of
inflation exceeding 10 for the first
time in 40 years
the telegraph's headline Britain has the
worst inflation in the G7
the guardian says 45 million people can
find themselves in fuel poverty as a
result of the cost of living crisis
the eye reports that an increase in
interest rates could come soon
The Daily Express warns of a shock rise
to interest rates facing homeowners
describing ministers as being on a war
footing
well given that she gets 13 weeks
holiday a year the star accuses Liz
truss of hypocrisy for saying British
people need to work harder
the Metro has the story of 87 year old
Thomas O'Halloran who was stabbed to
death on his mobility scooter in West
London
the male asks what kind of monster kills
an 87 year old on a scooter
and the sun reports on an offer from one
of Britain's richest men sir Jim
Radcliffe to buy Manchester United amid
a disastrous start for the new season
for the club
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Andrew Pierce and Kevin McGuire lovely
to see you both now the economy
dominating pretty much all of the front
pages apart from this Dreadful story
about the the 87 year old man who was
killed on the mobility scooter
um so let's kick off with that and the
financial times at Andrew to you first
of all 10 for the first time inflation
has been this High Thatcher was in
government not something you necessarily
will be celebrating
it's Bleak there's no way of dressing it
up Jane it is the worst figure in the G7
it's not the worst in the European Union
by any by any means but it's bad and
it's the trouble is it's going to get
worse Fuel and it's going and and with
it's with the energy the energy problem
is going to make it much worse so some
suggestions by January it will Peak at
13 or 14 now there's no there's barely
any encouragement in the figures at all
because I know we we now know that fuel
prices put people's pet because they're
putting pets in the car is starting to
come down and that will feed through
eventually but as we always know
um they're always much quicker quicker
to put prices up and take prices down
but this now shows the scale of the
magnitude of the challenge the next
prime minister and it also underlines
the how infuriating it is that this
wretched Tory leadership contest is
going on and on and on and on and on
when we pretty much know this trust as
one and she's the latest poll puts her
on 6 62 percent or something we just
want the new prime minister in number 10
calling that emergency budget and
spelling out the detail of how they're
going to help people get through this
because families will not be able to do
this on their own and Kevin the the
leadership campaign clearly has been a
distraction but did you hold out any
hope that we will see inflation pausing
when it peaks in the spring or as you're
concerned that it it could keep on
Rising
I think everybody's concern as it could
keep on Rising the bank of England uh
predicting it all or forecasting it'll
go over uh 13 we've not heard anything
from Liz Tross who's the likely next
prime minister to be installed without a
general election by the conservative
cult not heard anything from her uh that
would make you think she'll be able to
bring it down in any way when she
opposes an energy level freeze which
would play play a part I noticed uh
Andrew brexit Andrew were very quick to
say it's not the highest uh in the
European Union I look forward to him now
telling us which countries have higher
rates but as the Ft points out it is the
highest in the G7 that's the I said that
economy well I said that no well I said
that Kevin don't you listen to anything
very size in the G7 I'm sure you're
going to announcement
go to Belgium they've got hiring they've
got higher inflation going but he he it
was likes and there's truss like to
heart back to Margaret Thatcher well
unfortunately we are now back to
Margaret Thatcher and the this 40 year
high and like 10 10.1 inflation
essentially means your standard living
or your wages you have lost a tenth of
that that is a huge hit that's why
there's enormous pressure on the
government to do something to help
people protect people Shield them uh why
I think it's unfair to attack workers
who are trying to defend their living
standards and also where where are the
government policies when the Bull of the
taxes that uh Liz truss would cut will
go to a very wealthy corporations being
born to them as Rishi sunako rival would
say and you reverse the National
Insurance uh rise which made maybe the
right policy most money will again go to
High appendix and uh those at the bottom
particularly people who rely on top-ups
through the benefit system into
Universal Credit I'm just going to be
absolutely crucified this is a real
crisis Here and Now Andrew has the
government made mistakes that have got
us to this point the conservative party
has been in power for so long and now we
are in this position and as you said you
know there are only a handful of
countries in Europe that are worse than
us at the moment yeah look it's not good
there's no doubt about it and I don't
think what's been going on I mean we've
had a pandemic we've had uh the war on
Ukraine all these are factors which have
been a a big part of the problem and it
is a global problem rapid inflation is
the highest in America for 40 years but
I think the governor of the banking
there's a huge question marks over
whether he was quick he was he was he
asleep at the wheel should interest
rates have gone up sooner because that
is one of the cruder levers you can use
to try to control inflation uh and if
the interest rates have been an historic
low for a very long time so should they
have moved quicker but that's a matter
of Interest rates in the end of the day
aren't a matter for the chancellor or
the Prime Minister because the the the
the the banking has Independence there
but they can influence policy as much as
they can but I you do wonder I'm not an
economist but in which should interest
rates have gone up sooner because that
and they are going to go up again to try
and slow down the rate of inflation they
probably should have gone up sooner
Kevin in terms of interest rates
potentially going up that is um what
we're seeing on the front of the express
that's its front page the ft is going
with inflation the telegraph is going
worse than the G7
um the express like this likely interest
rate hike
um this is not good news for for those
who are are lucky enough to have been
able to scrape enough pennies together
to get a mortgage is it
no you're absolutely right uh Jane and
the the medicine could be as as bad as
the illness if the economy is going to
crash into a recession that the bank of
England is is now predicting a 15-month
period And if people can't afford to pay
their mortgages can't afford to pay
loans can't afford to pay credit cards
well you can bring down inflation but
you're actually going to crucify them in
another way this is a terrible situation
and Andrew said he's no Economist that's
quite right he's not but he he's got
he's got to explain in some ways an
enthusiastic supporter of this
conservative government and all the
other conservative governments why the
rate of inflation in the UK is the
highest in the G7 now brexit is
certainly a part of that because the
pound is so weak since uh brexit and
it's had other hits on trade and so on
but this is a this is a bad situation
the government can't be blamed for
everything because the war in Ukraine is
undoubtedly said and food and fuel
prices rising globally but why is the UK
being hit harder than other other
economies we've got a long-term problem
we know that we've had very low growth
for far too long we've also got low
productivity uh and now what what is the
government going to do about it and you
don't hear anything from Liz truss the
likely winner the likely next uh
installed prime minister without the
general uh without the general election
that will give any hope to people who
really are incredibly worried and
rightly sore because they might have
been able to make ends meet before but
they won't be
nowhere they are going to see their
living standards destroyed and Andrew do
you ever think anything there that
brexit is a contributory factor to the
economic state that we're in at the
moment
well there's that we can argue I think
brexit it's the wrong thing to argue
about right now but Kevin says she said
nothing listra she says immediately
she's going to get rid of the suspend
the green levy on our energy bills that
will be 25 now that's something Kevin
mcgorry
it's a huge sale on people's bills and
why do you ignore it why do you ignore
it because you don't agree with it Kevin
because you still want to whack people
with as much taxes as possible she's
also said she's going to cut National
Insurance that's a big make a big
difference to people who are working and
I when she gets in there'll be an
emergency budget and there will be help
for people who are on benefits you can
be certain it's ridiculous to say she's
saying nothing and doing nothing you're
deaf I know we're suffering we're
suffering in inflation we're suffering
inflation from Andrew now it is not 25
the green Levy is much smaller and a
large part of that Levy goes one to the
warmer home scheme which subsidizes the
fuel bills of people from poor
households and secondly pays for
insulation programs which will reduce
the fuel bills of people on lower income
so Andrew is actually proposing or
backing or trumpeting championing a
scheme that will make it harder for
those on Lower incomes as well as
inflating the size of that Levy what it
will do is put money back in people's
pockets immediately it's an immediate
palpable effect and there's Kevin on the
labor party opposing it of course they
are because they're more obsessed about
green issues than the cost of living
crisis affecting people do you support
freezing bills
Uh Kevin I don't think I do not support
what the labor party proposing because I
don't think you and me should get our
bills Frozen Kevin because we can afford
to pay the increase and I'd rather see
the money that helped targeted on
families who are really struggling
that's not me and that's not you I don't
know if you take you and you and I out
what about the other 20 times
we usually freeze their bills
Kevin I'm not supporting the labor party
policy which is ridiculous it's a
scatter gun a policy freeze the bills
for everybody so the Queen's Bill gets
frozen Tony Blairsville gets frozen the
governor of the bank then it's crazy the
international monetary fund though less
says that is not the way to do it you
should be targeting Aid where it's most
badly needed and that is not the labor
party way but Andrew at the same time
you would give uh you mean everybody
else who answered the question you you
would give them back a green Levy would
you I would you give them the green Levy
you don't like the answer which is why
you're changing the subject I I am
pointing the contradiction in your
position you don't like the answer
you're changing the subject back no I
like your answer I like your answer
because it feels lost that's why I like
your answer because it reveals a lot
about your values and what you care
about we're gonna take your gloves off
and pause for a moment uh we're gonna
take a short break I'm sure you'll have
lots to talk about during it
but after the break we will return uh
this would normally be news but it
rained however it is a case of be
careful what you wish for we will
discuss that next
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview and with me now Andrew Pierce
and Kevin McGuire are taking us through
their choices of the front pages and
some of the inside Pages as well and we
are looking inside inside the Metro uh
which is which is really focused on the
weather in London the rain that has come
after the hot hot weather and of course
all the hose pipe bands some great
photographs that they've got on this on
this page here inside floody hell uh
headline we knew it was coming didn't we
but uh Kevin it was a bit wet out there
earlier
no no it was other parts of the country
Scotland bits of Wales north of England
uh Southwest have had this for for a few
days uh if not weeks but of course now
it's hit uh it's hit London and um the
Metro is is very good with its uh with
its headlines for the hell kind of uh
kind of gets it and it never rains but
it pours you you won't water uh papers
were full of uh warnings by Thames water
today that uh horse pipe bands are going
to be started next week and there you
are you've got a load of rain but it
after a long drought knocking off and
given the amount of water the private
ice water companies leak it just won't
be enough to uh to stop but the big
problem of course is that because it has
been so dry and because the ground is so
hard Andrew that this rain is just
running off which is why it is flooding
um do you think what's happened this
summer is perhaps given a lot of people
more pause for thought about what they
do with their front driveways for
example Paving over everything and what
we do as a society in terms of open
spaces and the amount of of Nature and
land that we allow to stay open
I'm sure that's what's is going to
happen Jane and I think there will be
long-term consequences and I think also
though it's encouraging quite a lot of
people to take
um their own little measures so I mean
I've been if I've been watering my
garden it's been water I've used in the
kitchen or in the bathroom so I'm not
wasting water if you know what I mean
and the washing machine goes on much
less as always we can help save water
but what is so infuriating is we get
that text message from Thames water
today saying there's going to be a hose
pipe down from next week the heavens
open two hours later a flood of biblical
proportions and it's because these
wretched water companies are losing
around 25 of water in leagues every
single day it is so infuriating because
they're not investing enough of their
profits in rest in in investing in a
modern uh network of pipe Network and
there's and and of course some of the
directors some of the bosses are taking
millions of pounds in payments and it's
outrageous and it really I think it's
making people really Furious Kevin's
going to go on about another Tory
privatization before he does let me just
say the only players government and
Gordon Brown's government had 13 years
to reverse it and they didn't okay he's
making
starmer has just abandoned labor party
policy to re-nationalize the water
industry so sorry Kevin you're going
nowhere with us and Kevin we spoke last
week about this on the pay-per-view and
you were saying the hose pipe bands are
really unfair to those with disabilities
I got the pin through today as well and
it was interesting to note that actually
uh if you have got mobility issues
you're exempt from the hose pipe band if
you need to to use a hose pipe in order
to wash your gun because you can't
manage a water and can there is
provision for that so that's something
to celebrate
yeah no it is you're quite right and I I
endorse Andrew's critique of a
disastrous uh privatization another by
uh by Margaret Thatcher here's heroin
um she'll be wilting in that cardboard
cut out in his house when uh until he
hears him attacking that by organization
I think sooner it's in public ownership
again the battery off but no you pretend
to answer your specific question yes it
is good and it's fair and the truth is
it's very hard to prosecute people
because the water companies are asking
you to shop a neighbor snoot on your
neighbor I don't think those britons
will do that you've got a bit of a
during code you'll get a few curtain
Twitches who'd be malicious but most
people uh are not like that and uh
anyway I suspect those are going to
water their Gardens or their their plans
during a horse fight battle probably be
out at five six in the morning when
others aren't up when I was asleep uh
final quick look at the Daily Star it's
a front page so this is about out uh the
comments that Liz trust made about
people having to work harder uh they're
saying she has 13 weeks holidays is that
true Andrew would you say no no did you
get a big break over the summer don't
they in a big a big break of Easter
Prime Ministers were Prime Ministers and
were flat out well prime minister yeah
whatever yeah but they but they were
flat out and uh and even when they're on
holiday they're working she didn't
actually say that where the people are
lazy she just said we need more graft
and there's no doubt about it
productivity in this country has been a
huge problem for years and years
particularly in the last 20 years I
don't know what why it's such a problem
but she was right to raise it